siamo ragazzi e benvenuti al 195esimo
episodio di happy meal allora sono molto
emozionato perché il ogni cinque episodi
io faccio uno special il prossimo quinto
episodio cene senza altri cinque episodi
faccio lo speciale 200.200 airbus e
cattivo faceva speciale 202 centesimi
episodi e da questa settimana in poi
ragazzi
ogni video di happy days che esce sarà
un po specialino specialmente il 199 e
il 200 ovviamente saranno molto speciali
quindi se l'emozionato molti si
emozionano per un matrimonio la nascita
di un figlio un bel voto a scuola io no
sono emozionato per i 200 episodi di
epiche se la mia vita è questa allora
vediamo di fare le cose fatte giuste
perché siamo negli ultimi episodi poi
non farò mai più e chi visse nella mia
vita
il vostro è in treno fantasma non che lo
ior l'ho mai fatto non mi ricordo il
livello di maturità porco il demonio che
cagà salve guido io non guido io sto su
minchia che partenza di creare aiuto il
cast e maroni non avevo mai fatto questo
salve e la salve degli avvoltoi del cup
di vaio che continuato sei proprio io
sono morto ma mai figlio gamal facciamo
tutti noi vai figlio bravo tutto giusto
[Musica]
ma c'era una fine il suo livello quanto
concreto da action congratulazione per
la nuova produzione detective cullen
come edward lavorano solo per far sì che
le crimine sia sradicato la presa città
via marghera
oddio oddio di no del successo di chi è
che mi stata non ho capito cosa è
successo
sono seguito la trama sono io con mia
moglie
sono vivo tesoro per facili storm tesoro
tesoro non ho seguito l'inter nella
trama spero abbiate capito vuoi perché
io non ho capito niente
c 4 c 42 c 43 c 44 45 non c'è ok tesoro
spara tesoro spara spara parco lemonia
zio come amore aggrappati senza arti
continuiamo con la forza del cuore
sono vivo non so come ecco perfetto
amore guidato guida tesoro guida brava a
mora di subito io stop per forza oddio
mi sei incastrato lo stomaco nel camion
mi ha tirato indietro non la penso come
migliore
questa è prevista signori questo è happy
winsock riproviamoci perché un livello
pazzesco
veramente no
benissimo chi è che ha avuto l'idea
geniale di fare una roba del genere che
alzi chi ha avuto l'idea c'è un genio è
stato un genio che fa questa roba
amore occhio c4 l'amore per il mio
orecchio confronti e molto esplosivo
ok riproviamoci stavolta siamo attaccati
alcuni camion se come non dobbiamo stare
attaccati al collo le camere direi che
possiamo provare l'ultima perché proprio
talmente difese la facciamo sono queste
ragazze purtroppo è così quindi
riproviamoci l'ultima volta speriamo da
bere a mare
occhio alle bombe ci penso io tu
avvertimi si arrivava da dietro
l'aspetto l'andamento è quello corretto
a mare
vabbè è un livello impossibile però
fatto veramente bene peccato ocarina of
time
io non sono link però proviamoci lo
stesso ciao
al che io non sono non devo prendere io
la principessa zelda sicuro perché in
questo momento mi sento proprio tutto
fuorché il l'eroe di zelda però fa
niente ok
oddio oddio oddio cambiamola non mi
piaceva proprio mato mato in che senso
ma turbato dio che cacchio sono che poi
tu senti uomo rosa e lo sapevo che
domandargli l'aiuto che mi dici ma lo
sapevo già
ma lo sapevo già cristo è che hanno
perso ma cosa è successo cos'è forse
devo semplicemente correre a di active
no no no no il cast di activate che qua
non so giocare normalmente bergamo
dovevo solo correre tutto sto casino era
facile come faccia salire la montagna
non posso a grazie giudizio che mi
spingevo va beh devo pure saltare in
tutto questo sembra un cartone di
cartoon network sto tizio alla fammi
salire normale normale normale normale
ok non era difficile
solo che il primo è che io giochi
tutto a posto
ok è non aver usa sia successo per ora
le slot avevo quasi finito credo spero
perché già difficile
metti un finale sono cagato sotto
sequestro vi state chiedendo la risposta
è sì dove sto finendo dove è dove sono
continuerò a registrare finché il bello
che è stato fermo per quattro episodi
sono quattro episodi che registro è
stato sempre fermo qual è il problema
adesso è un cannone questo show ecco ho
sfondato tutto tutto bene ragazzi si lo
so che devo dargli la c'e solo una via
quindi non stai tranquillo è ovvio
oddio oddio corrie ma st lo vedo mi
avete preso per il culo ed in realtà
guest riesco a esce la mia faccia e
tutta una messa in scena in realtà non
sto comandando lui è solito sono arriva
un'importante serviva a niente anche
scoperto che è il vero personaggio che
sta dentro il personaggio quindi
figurati posso andare sotto ok come
succede ma dalla sinistra
ok dove stia mandando una cosetta via
cos'è a cosa sto già cosa sto facendo
spiegatevi ok da che parte vado sempre a
sinistra ma fa addio
ciao ragazzi tutto a posto verso la
vittoria
non so neanche dove è salito al cos'è
allora faccia incazzatissima è una bomba
cosa sto vedendo che livello è questo
vado giù da un elefante abbiamo chiamato
gioco c'è un livello e un porco il
demonio e quanto grosso queste pazze mio
zio
oddio che vabbè ma non puoi c'è devo
lasciare i miei figli per terra e non mi
immagino come se vai vai figli via i
rallentate i rallentate ciò che le fan
tener duro
sono gigante sono vivo sono vivo
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai non sono
più vivo
[Musica]
ok prova a risaltare sopra l'elefante
magari ecco mi aggrappo non a mio figlio
cazzo aggrappati a tutto tranne che a
tuo figlio che cacchio serve tuo figlio
ma tagli lo hai fatto a fare tuo figlio
non serve posso finire un livello oggi
ragazzi ma è più un gioco dove
teoricamente potresti finire dei livelli
ma non ne sono sicuro c'è teoricamente
vive lì dovrebbero avere una prima di
meno vista neanche una oggi dovrebbe
favorire le vorrei vedermi minuti mi
eroga è però è però mi ero aggrappato
ero riuscito quindi penso non si possa
fare aggrappandosi semplicemente perché
mi ero veramente aggrappato troppo ok
sto andando avanti in una maniera un
pelo strana
vabbè poi queste quelle fatte da tavola
in realtà non è un elefante un volatile
troppo cresciuto pedala pedala quanto
lenta pedalata una gamba sono con
l'arrivo di ogni marchio ami arpionato
ma sono ancora vivo e credibile vai vai
bene anche non è finita ma che non è
finita ma che non è finita salis alisa
ii salì sono di soldi sono di solito
giarre signora attenzione che ci state
le foto gigante occhio mi ha tirato un
calcio sono vivo oddio aree volate cribe
sì certo tesoro vedi come sono in vena
di fare un giro e quindi a è finito così
posso avere una scritta vittoria fino
alla fine una una sola via per favore
una sola scritta vita è una sola per me
bad land una sola per per il buon farvi
una scritta vittoria una sola click to
skype inter non me ne frega sembra lì
imposto a livello rega ma non ha mai
fatto benissimo solito sembra veramente
limbo
chissà se riuscirò a finirlo fandango
lauren ciak perché quindi demandare di
sotto e vedere se sia aperto qualcosa
nostro genere
effettivamente bello e fatto veramente
bene suo livello porca vacca anche con
le cose cliccabili che le cose cliccati
non è facile trovarle livelli che hanno
proprio le cose interagibili col mouse
perché non è è una feature che è stata
messa molto dopo in happiness nel 2015
però è sempre tanto dopo conscio la
chiave great farei bisogno di una guida
per finire il labirinto che ora spetta
dottore tutti indietro perché si trova a
sbloccare il madonna difficilissimo
specie di prova dei e ho capito ma mi fa
arrivare di partire per questo vabbè dai
riproviamoci l'ultima volta vediamo se
riesco arrivare ad una scritta vittoria
questa è l'ultima ragazzi e l'ultimo
tentativo di oggi vediamo o la va o la
spacca
[Musica]